Oh,
yours are that we will not get our,
uh,
environment under control.
The barriers are that,
uh,
I saw a very interesting film,
a few,
it was on a French television program.
It would be showing,
some people come up,
uh,
from,
they had been nomads in the south,
uh,
part of the desert in western Africa.
And there was a fishing season and they
arrived in trucks and they,
thousands of them went out and we were
catching these fish.
And pretty soon there were no fish left.
That was the point of the film.
And the real point of the film is,
well,
there aren't gonna be any fish lab.
But the message was,
what are they supposed to do?
What are they supposed to do?
There isn't work for them where they
started,
uh,
they have to eat.
And so they come up and they take the
fish.
Well,
this is a huge problem and we know that
on the one hand,
we've got to keep the fish and we also
have to find work for the paper.
And so that's the kind of problem that's
posed.
Tremendous environmental problems,
tremendous population problems,
uh,
tremendous problems,
of course,
of keeping the,
what I'd call the fanatical,
dark element of human nature under
control.
And it only takes a few where it's out
of control to do tremendous damage.
But we have terrific instruments of
cooperation.
The Internet being one,
our educational institutions,
uh,
our economy is good.
We have this economic means,
so forces of points of light and
possibilities of,
okay.